everybody i talked to actually thought
it's a bad idea like any reasonable
person would have quit i was filled with
self-doubt and then coinbase was valued
at a billion dollars crazy brian
armstrong ceo co-founder of coinbase
largest u.s cryptocurrency exchange i
saw technology as a way to try to have a
big impact on the world if the thing
that got you started in the first place
was like fear like fear of never being
important or fear of never feeling
fulfilled you're just gonna give up
cryptocurrency is the biggest
transformation of money since the
invention of paper coinbase was being
deemed the most trustworthy brand in
crypto it tipped at a certain point from
like oh this growth is really good to
okay things are getting a little crazy
here if you kind of more than double a
company in a year you're really going to
start to see a lot of stuff break
this morning coinbase just telling
employees in an email that it plans to
lay off 18 of its workforce we had never
done a layoff before i had never done
one i remember i went up in for the
company and my voice
cracked
i mean it was awful
oh man
i actually think coinbase is in deep
trouble here and let me tell you why the
pressure
and the scrutiny and the headlines how
are you dealing with your emotions
this is getting very personal
it's a real superpower to like care less
what other people think
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
brian
i when i read through people's people's
stories they're sometimes really obvious
um causal factors that led them to
become the people they are today
but with you i'm i'm more compelled by
the less obvious factors if we go back
to your early years when you're a young
man on the west coast yeah of the united
states
what are the the less obvious reasons as
to why you've ended up where you are
today and achieved what you've achieved
in your life
great question um
one of the less obvious reasons probably
is that
i was an introvert i just wasn't really
very good with people i didn't really
have that many friends you know as a
young person
i was quite shy um i really
found a love of computers and i liked
just being by myself and playing with
computers learning about how they worked
programming and
you know in our
technological age i suppose um
some of the people who got excited about
computers early on and just have found a
love of building things have now become
you know ceos of companies which is kind
of a strange thing for a long time i
didn't think i could be a ceo because
i envisioned ceos of companies as being
like these military generals who barked
orders at people and they were these
like strong charismatic leaders and
i always felt like well that's not me
i'm kind of like an engineer i'm kind of
a nerd you know and what i've learned
over time is now reading enough books
and things historically
you know introverts can make actually
really good ceos um of course by the way
there's lots of different types of ceos
there's not just one mold there's people
who love marketing people have
operations people who love sales people
and then there are engineer ceos
um
so that's one reason that i think it's
maybe a little bit less known why i'm
here
another another reason is that
i just became very passionate about this
idea of trying to have an impact on the
world and i think it again may have come
from that that introversion as a kid and
i felt like hey i have good ideas but
it's hard for me to get them out there
and for people to listen to them and
i didn't feel confident like you know
speaking in some public setting or
whatever i have lots of practice doing
it now so i can i'm a well-trained
introvert but um
you know i saw technology as a way to
try to have a big impact on the world
and it could get my ideas out there in a
scalable way even if i felt like maybe i
couldn't and so i don't know maybe
that's another
un unlikely reason in hindsight then
going back to those early years as well
what was your
luck or privilege what were the factors
that were out of your control that
happened to be the case that also aided
to that um trajectory yeah i mean there
was a lot of things that went right so i
was in a home with loving parents that
were very supportive of education and my
passions and interests including you
know my mother worked at ibm and so we
had like an early computer in our home
um she was kind of an early programmer
there you know we had early access to
internet things like that i also had you
know i graduated studied i studied
computer science and economics and i had
um
enough
this was a very important thing i was
not afraid to go try starting companies
because i knew that if i failed i could
actually go back and still get a job
and it wasn't people always think of you
know entrepreneurs oh they're such risk
takers and all the stuff
you know
honestly it's not it's not that risky
like if you're a young person and
you
get a little bit of money to go start a
company like in in silicon valley people
write you angel checks for these things
and you can pay yourself a salary go try
it for a couple years and it doesn't
work you go back to a company and you
it's often viewed as a badge of honor um
that you've tried to start up you have
this entrepreneurial dna you're somehow
more valuable inside a company now if it
doesn't work and you go back
in many places in the world that's not
the case you know failure of a company
is considered a badge a mark of shame
not a badge of honor
and then
i think many people don't have the
luxury of being able to kind of raise
these seed rounds and things like that
which many places in the world you can't
do that crypto is trying to help that by
the way but in silicon valley you can
get angel checks for things and so
i tried starting many different things
over the years as kind of as side
projects but with coinbase specifically
i didn't really i didn't even quit my
job to try it full time until i had
gotten sort of an angel investment so
i was able to pay myself something it
wasn't a lot but i was able to pay
myself something and de-risk it um yeah
if i'd asked you then at say 10 years
old what you what you wanted to be when
you grew up what would you have told me
at 10 years old i mean i really
i really had no idea i think the first
glimmer of it that i had was in high
school
and i i had started building some
websites and i remember as a senior in
high school i went on this retreat and
uh i had i do remember having this
thought like
the thing that has excited me the most
in my life so far was i had built this
kind of simple website or app and
it felt like it was this really
incredible feeling i went to sleep and i
woke up in the morning and i checked the
stats and like you know 200 people or
something had visited the website while
i was sleeping and i was like wow that
was so cool i don't know who these
people are they're all over the world it
felt like a superpower like if i could
build something that could be
working and helping people while i was
sleeping
you know if not if not 200 people why
not 2 000 2 million whatever and so i do
remember having sort of a
it's stuck in my memory like that of all
the things i've tried in my life you
know sports and reading and science and
in school and whatever as a high
schooler that was the thing that really
got me excited in a way that nothing
else had at that point so i was probably
in the very early stages of discovering
my passion at that point
just just listening to you speak there
my my brain was telling me that because
i was trying to make this link between
why being an introvert led you to
technology and then also having this
sort of desire to have impact but it
sounds like there technology allowed you
to be be an introvert and have impact
because it was the the bridge between
the the outside world yeah so when that
website goes live you don't have to see
these people or persuade them yeah but
you can have your impact by by a piece
of technology that's enabling something
in their lives exactly
you go off and study economics
in university and yeah college yeah so i
had been taking some programming classes
um on the side in high school
i couldn't help it i i i like in my free
time
i would just play with computers until
like two in the morning three in the
morning i was like dead tired at school
every day because i was like wide awake
at night like playing with computers
learning about linux and like all these
things
and um
school was a little bit boring in some
ways
so
yeah i basically decided okay if i'm in
this interested in computers my parents
were supportive of this of course there
was like community college classes and i
went to go try to take some of those
classes to learn programming there was i
got some books from the library about
like how to program java and things like
that and i couldn't i couldn't
understand any of it
but i was trying to
work my way through it so then when it
came time to go to college i was
basically like okay computer science
that seems like the closest thing to
what i'm interested in i was also
interested in business and they didn't
offer a business degree so i studied
economics instead that was like the
closest thing to a business degree they
offered and
that was literally my my thinking now of
course i had no idea later i'd started
crypto company which was literally the
intersection of computer science and
economics but yeah at the time i just
thought i want to
i want to write software and i want to
learn how to start a business
and at some point during college you
start your first
i guess real company
yeah which is a tutoring business yeah
was that
did you have grand plans of turning that
into a a mega was that or did you
stumble into that
more like stumbled into it yeah i mean
so
as a college student my roommates and i
were always trying to think about how to
make extra money and i went around and i
was looking at these on-campus jobs so
you could work at the library there was
like a coffee shop
and you know they paid like 10 15 an
hour or something like that
and one of the upper classmen
i remember he told me you know i'm
tutoring this high school kid and
they're paying me 60 an hour i was like
wow
60 an hour is it just it was like three
or four x what you could make at these
other on-campus jobs
so i decided to try doing it myself
i got in touch with some people i
started tutoring high school kids just
in like math and science and things like
that and it paid really well and so my
roommate and i at the time we were
starting to just brainstorm like why
don't we start a little tutoring company
and help high school kids and their
parents match with you know the you know
tutors at the basically university
students at the university where i was
going to school
and so we got that going we got maybe 10
20 of our of our fellow students kind of
connected in
and then we said all right let's make a
website for this to connect even more
people maybe try to expand it to other
schools
you know eventually
over a period of a couple years this
this idea just kept evolving and we
started to think about it as we didn't
really know this at the time but it was
we were kind of making an online
marketplace like airbnb for but but for
tutoring
and um yeah i got to practice like
building web applications um there was
payroll and incorporation and sales and
marketing and taxes and
um
it i could never really get it to grow
enormous and to make it become like a
really big business which we can talk
about if you want but that was the seed
of it that later
became a little bit more of a company
why then why couldn't you make it become
a big business what was the
in hindsight the lesson yeah the barrier
okay so we learned this sort of the hard
way about creating a marketplace which
was that in this particular industry in
tutoring a lot of times uh you would
introduce a
student and a tutor
and they would sort of we our business
we were trying to take like a 10 fee by
matching these people and we were
basically trying to do all the payments
through our website like billing and you
know
with a 10 fee and what would happen
often is they would meet the tutor if
and they'd do initially the first
payment but then afterwards they'd start
paying them under the table and so um
we were i realized at a certain point we
were basically just getting in the way
they they wanted us to just match them
but they didn't want us to be the whole
billing apparatus it was a much more
like a local
repeat business in-person business and
so for years and years i struggled with
that
there was a counterintuitive moment
which allowed me to kind of pivot away
from that so i eventually realized this
thing isn't working i need to go get a
quote-unquote real job
and
as i was going to
start my the real job this was at um
basically airbnb where i became an early
employee
i was i was about to shut down the
tutoring site and i was like feeling a
lot of pain about that because like well
i don't know there are still like five
ten thousand people every month who are
kind of looking at this thing and using
it it feels like such a pain to shut it
down
or such a bad thing so i was like what
if what if i were just to put everything
on autopilot you know we're not gonna be
involved in any of the payments there's
no customer support this is literally
just going to be a directory like a
tutoring directory and you can contact
these tutors you can pay them however
you want
um
and i'm just going to try to make it
like a free thing maybe i'll put up some
ads
and so i basically had like a week
before i was starting my my new job i
got rid of all the payments i messaged
all the people using it i was like you
can pay now people directly
and um i was gonna put up some ads and i
did one more thing at the last hour
which is i said if you want to have like
a featured profile as a tutor
with like a little badge on a featured
badge and come up first in search
results then you can just pay 10 a month
and that was it and i basically
stopped looking at the website and i
went to go focus on my new job
and every year thereafter the site
doubled after i made that change
um and so basically i guess the lesson
was you know
stop trying to extract value and start
trying to create more value and at that
point i think that was only the the only
tutoring directory online that had free
profiles and you could just contact the
tutors and so it actually started to
grow
later later uh um somebody ended up
acquiring it for maybe like two million
dollars or something so to me that was
like
it was like a seven or eight year
base hit the outcome yeah where for
years you know five six years i was
struggling to get anything to work but
the the truth is okay they paid two
million dollars for it yeah but the
lessons you learn
uh many of those translate into the
business that you went on to build in
coinbase what is there anything else
because i look at my first startup that
i made out of you know dropping out of
university then started yeah and there's
so many lessons one of them is what you
said is i was i was so romantic about my
hypothesis about what this business
should be that i got in the way of what
customers wanted to do yeah so hearing
you say that really relates but is there
anything else that you learned from that
seven-year first
you know kind of messy startup that
of key philosophies for you today in
coinbase
i mean i think one of the big
realizations i had in starting that
tutoring company which again you can you
can always look back and see how the the
pieces connect but at the time you're
just wandering in the desert you're lost
like i felt i felt like i was a failure
i felt like i had no idea what i even
wanted to do i didn't even know if i
wanted to be an entrepreneur it
basically wasn't working but looking
back with hindsight
one thing i realized was how broken
the global financial system was because
it was incredibly difficult to
collect money from all these students
and pay these tutors
not only in the us but in various places
around the world and i remember um going
through this pro like incredibly onerous
process to like set up credit card
processing and then
payments that i was sending out and i
remember the bank called me one day and
they were like
you know are you an aggregator of funds
and i was like i don't even know what
that is and they were basically like
treating me like almost like i was a
criminal and what are your licenses to
do all this stuff and i was like this is
crazy it was the hardest one of the
hardest things about that business was
just to get the payments like collecting
payments and distributing payments to
the tutors as a marketplace
and so that gave me sort of a real
insight later when i saw the bitcoin
white paper years later i was like
that system is broken um and this could
be an opportunity to fix it so that was
one thing what about airbnb so you went
and worked as a in the product team at
airbnb yeah yeah i was a technical
product manager which basically meant i
wrote some code and i tried to be a
product manager yeah um
yeah so i think i was the 40th employee
at airbnb and i basically
moved back to silicon valley from i was
living in buenos aires argentina for a
year or so trying to figure out what i
wanted to do with my life okay i'm gonna
have to
talk about that sure yeah what did that
give you that experience of travel and
going to argentina and living there for
how many years
a little less than a year yeah what did
that give you
well it gave me a few things i mean one
was that i got to see what a
hyperinflation economy looked like you
know
a lot of people have only grown up grown
up in a developed country they've never
experienced hyperinflation and they've
never felt firsthand what that
can really do for a population and
people
so i would it really deeply affects the
culture of places like argentina there's
just there's kind of this
deep distrust of
um the government and there's a
pessimism about about the future there's
kind of you know in countries that i
think are the most forward thinking
there's a sense of optimism about the
future hey we can build a better future
and there's you know in places like
argentina might you know people may
disagree my impression was that people
felt like
the best days are behind us and
live every day like it's your last
because hey it could all disappear
tomorrow meaning your wealth and
everything which has happened many times
in their history
also just little things like you'd go to
the restaurant the next week and the
prices are higher and they put a sticker
on top of the menu because the prices
keep changing so so frequently it really
it really harms like the poorest people
in in society too because they they're
the ones holding their wealth in cash as
opposed to wealthy people can hold real
estate things that adjust for inflation
now they can hold bitcoin
um so anyway it gave me a front row seat
into that
it probably gave me a little bit of a
sense of confidence too because i had
never
studied abroad or
really um
lived in a foreign country by myself
where i didn't really speak the language
very well so there was things like that
i think i was just trying to learn how
to become more independent and grow up
and stuff like that you were running the
tutoring business at this point yeah i
mean i was doing a lot of things so i
was running the tutoring business i was
um doing some contract software
development just kind of while traveling
i was
trying to build some real estate
investments
in the in the us i i was basically
trying to figure what i want to do with
my life and there was a whole
process i went through to try to figure
that out if you're curious too
the digital nomad piece which is
becoming much more common these days
because we've had this pandemic and
we've kind of built systems which allow
us to work more remotely and but just
generally people were were choosing that
lifestyle when i did that when i was 21
in the gap between my startup failing
and then me pivoting into a new business
i found it quite lonely
and there was i remember being actually
on a plane flying from one country to
another brazil to thailand or something
and seeing this
um i think it was textiles or something
like this
san francisco incubator or new
york-based incubate where they were
building companies and i was i was
living the dream in many people's eyes
in these hot countries with my laptop
but something inside me was like missing
yeah um community a sense of shared
mission whatever it is i wonder i wonder
if you
you can relate to that in any way or
totally i i found it actually quite
lonely as well so in in some ways that
was the point which was to step outside
my comfort zone feel like i had to make
new friends in new city but yeah i mean
there was a good you know maybe
five six months there in buenos aires
where i felt like i didn't really know
that many people
um i was feeling kind of homesick yeah
eventually i tried to you know go meet
some local people like expats like
various
hostels and like you know event by the
time i left i felt like i had a budding
friend group and i liked it more but it
was lonely there for a while
you said you used that time to figure
out what you wanted to do with your life
as if there's some kind of system there
yeah i don't know if there's a perfect
system but i mean i read this book by
seth godin called the dip
yeah i don't know if you've read it but
and it's funny i went back to read it
like
many years later and it's actually a
relatively simple book but in that
moment in that time that's what i needed
to hear and it's kind of a very fairly
simple idea um which is that you know
what's the thing that you would still
want to be doing 10 years from now even
if you hadn't seen a lot of success
because most things in life you know you
start off you're a beginner you have a
fast pace of learning it's kind of fun
but then after you after you're a
beginner there's this dip in the middle
where you're not an expert you're not
one of the best people in the world
you're probably not making money from it
but you're not a beginner anymore and
there's like this long slog to go
through the middle you know put in your
10 000 hours there's lots of various
people have talked about this
so
i was doing a variety of things at that
time i was i was as i mentioned running
that tutoring company doing some real
estate investing i was like learning
martial arts and like all the various
things traveling in argentina
and i and i basically sat down one day i
was like what's this what is the thing
that i 10 years from now i'm still going
to want to do this and be passionate
about it
and even if i'm not successful at it you
know because i just love doing it
and like the only thing i could like
really write on my list was tech
entrepreneurship
and so par part of the point of that
book is
if if you're not willing to go through
the dip then then quit now because it's
you know and so i was like do i really
want to be like
doing
you know great real estate investments
10 years from i was like i don't
actually love real estate investing
so maybe i should have stopped doing
that maybe i should stop doing this and
maybe so it was this very clarifying
moment okay if i want to be a tech
entrepreneur because i had been doing
that in some way shape or form for you
know five ten years i was pretty sure
i'd be wanting to do it ten years from
now
i was like why do i live in buenos aires
i should go to where the
the center of tech entrepreneurship of
silicon valley you know that's happening
all over the world now silicon valley is
kind of decentralized but at that time
especially
so i kind of stopped doing everything
else
moved to silicon valley and
went all in on that and then
i think within maybe seven years of
making that decision um coinbase was
valued at a billion dollars crazy so it
did really help clarify my
ambitions and i just put it all into one
thing that is atypical
pointless yeah there's going to be
entrepreneurs in bruenesaras listening
to this that are bringing flights to san
francisco but it could it could be any
like if you really want to be an actor
you should probably go to hollywood or
something or if you really want to be in
finance maybe go to london new york or
anyway i think
it's not so i don't want to say like
there's one geography for everything but
um
there is a clarifying thing what happens
if you just say this is what is the most
important thing to me and i'm just gonna
try to make
luck my own luck around that
it's so true it's something that i don't
think especially young people think
about when they're deciding making
career choices they
where to live is sometimes not um as
prioritized as much as like which
university has the best partying or
who's offering me a job right now as
opposed to that long-term horizon of
like how do i surround myself with the
most talent and opportunity and funding
in the case of business um and
inspiration and enablers um for this
long-term vision i have and i spent some
time in san francisco myself about three
years and when i come back to the uk and
when i go to other cities in the uk i
i've never said this before but i see
how much of a disadvantage we have
in philosophy in ambition in funding in
talent
and um
it's no surprise that most of the great
unicorns that are emerging out of one
city and
in the world that then leads you to
airbnb somehow
through i think you take a job first
then eventually take a job at airbnb
yes exactly yeah i joined a y commenter
startup that was really cool but it
didn't really work out there was a brief
interlude there but
basically i i decided okay my tutoring
company is not really working i need to
and that's that's when i pivoted to that
thing which had a base hit but what i
decided all right i want to go to i want
you to go to silicon valley
i kind of want to apply to y combinator
it's a startup incubator
um
but i wasn't able to get in and so i was
like let me go work at a y combinator
company to sort of learn
and i need it by the way i also just
needed to recharge a little bit because
the tutoring company i've been living
abroad the shooting company wasn't
working i was
barely paying myself anything so i was
kind of broke
i was i was also just exhausted um
from the the tutoring company just not
working after so many years of trying to
get it to work
um and you know it hadn't seen it double
every year after that that happened on
the side um and so i was like great let
me take a job at a high growth company
that seems to be well run actually make
some money for a little bit here save
some money
and that's how i got to airbnb it just
it had a really
magnetic culture even at 40 people they
had they were clearly onto something it
had they had found product market fit it
was growing quickly
um and i learned a lot there they had a
really unique culture
um they they were hiring differently
they were really like trying to raise
the bar with every hire you know if it's
not a hell yes it's a no they were um
the way that they just did product
reviews was really interesting they had
an important design component to it
if you think about now
why airbnb
won in their market from what you got to
see inside their walls what would you
say so you've talked about their hiring
philosophy which is
very very clear yeah but what else would
you say
well the main thing and i think that by
the way this is true of not just airbnb
a lot of startups was determination
um
they went through a period everybody
always looks back to these startups and
they think oh it was a unicorn like it
just they found the thing and it worked
airbnb is actually somewhat typical in
this regard which was there was i think
at least um
i think like a three-year period where
they were just wandering in the desert
any reasonable person would have stopped
working on this idea it was it was a
crazy idea like it was like couchsurfing
you're gonna let strangers stay on my
couch like
that's not a business it's like just
ripe for lawsuits and you know
um
and they were in like tons of credit
card debt because they had like been
trying to sell fund it you know they had
launched several times and nobody was
using it um
yeah they should have quit like any
reasonable person would have quit
um but they didn't they kept going and
they were just because getting
marketplaces off the ground is very hard
you have to check an egg problem supply
and demand and so i actually think
that's a common element um in a lot of
like successful companies you go back
there there was a period where a normal
person just would have quit and they
they went from setback to setback to
setback with enthusiasm you know somehow
powering through it so
i learned that too i hear a lot of um
entrepreneurs who have your same
enthusiasm to be an entrepreneur
the enthusiasm you've expressed there
when you leave um argentina and you come
back you just want to be an entrepreneur
you don't necessarily know what or
industry what problem you want to solve
and what what always makes me feel a
little bit concerned is when an
entrepreneur is so keen to be an
entrepreneur that they'll just try and
think of an idea
you took a time to go and get inspired i
guess and to let the inspiration come to
you what's your view on that there'll be
people listening to this now that want
to be an entrepreneur but they don't
have an idea yeah
okay well i mean i i was probably guilty
of that too where there was definitely a
period in my life where i was like um i
just want to be an entrepreneur and i
don't know honestly it was probably
partly ego driven it was partly
um my own like introvert way of saying
like i just want to be able to have an
impact i wanted to feel like i had done
something valuable because i didn't feel
like valuable as a human myself like you
get into all the psychology of it right
it's kind of a crazy thing actually to
go
say like i have to be an entrepreneur
because
you know from an if you just want to
make money or something like it's from
an expected value outcome it's probably
better just to like go to some early
stage companies invest some equity and
like or join goldman sachs or something
right like so to be
truly want to be an entrepreneur i guess
you have to be
well sometimes it's ego driven but i
think it's your your chances of success
go up dramatically if you're doing
something because you're actually super
passionate about it and so for me
reading the bitcoin white paper was kind
of a lucky moment because
i found it tapped into something that i
was really passionate about which was
basically freedom you know um economic
freedom and just like how do we empower
people all over the world to you know
have access to sound money and um
like a decentralized open permit system
where anybody can get access to the
global financial system that really just
like resonated with me and so
i think that really helped coinbase be
successful because there were many times
in our history as a company where you
know like 20
2015 2016 like the whole industry was
down for three years everybody was
pivoting to do blockchain not bitcoin if
you remember that
every like a lot of the competitors in
space pivoted to make software for banks
and stuff
and everybody looks back at that and
like wow you know brian you never lost
faith and everything
for me it was more it was simple than
that i was just like well i don't really
want to make software for banks so like
if that's what this is all about now i'd
pretty much just gonna shut it down and
give the money back uh to investors um
so i was just too stubborn i was like i
i got into this because i feel like this
is the way to create more freedom in the
world so that's what i'm going to keep
doing
whether it works or not so i think there
is a really important element there you
have to be
super into it for some reason that's
bigger than just ego or trying to make
money or whatever because
every company is just filled with
setback after setback or setback and you
think you can power through it
but
believe me when you're like three years
in and like your co-founder quit and you
you got sued and you're broke and like
um
the first three times you launch the
product nobody wants to use it and like
everything sucks and you're feeling like
a failure and you're you know
you're just gonna give up because you're
not actually doing it for like some
bigger purpose you're doing it because
you wanted to feel important or
something so it actually is important to
pick the thing that you're passionate
about yeah you're doing it because you
want to feel important or something
we're talking about um how
part of this sort of introverts dilemma
is you can feel significant personal
significance by creating something that
has significance in the world
zooming right to the end of the story
has has that impact you've had on the
world made you feel more personally
significant
yeah totally okay so i think this is a
really important topic because a lot of
founder it's stressful to run a company
right
so a lot of founders if they do get to
some level of success they will often
burn out right
um
it shows up in weird ways by the way
some people gain a ton of weight some
people lose a lot of weight some people
deal with stress in all kinds of ways
i've there's like founders i've met that
get
like addicted to prescription drugs or
like
you know all kinds of unhealthy things
you can imagine right
so
um i mean you have to
find a way to shift from like if the
thing that got you started in the first
place was like fear like fear of never
being important or fear of never feeling
fulfilled you have to at some point
transition it
once that hole is filled in your heart i
guess you have to transition to being
motivated out of like joy or love or
something more positive not like running
away from fear and anger or you're like
you're really angry at this
you know your father or like the person
who um you know broke
like the co-founder who you almost was
going to found with who decided they
didn't want to and you're pissed at them
so you're trying to show them up or
whatever
those aren't relevant to me but i've
heard other examples
anyway long way of saying you have to
transition away from fear and anger as
your motivator to like joy and love and
just find the thing you actually love
doing in life so for me you know that
was like
figuring out what is the kind of ceo
role that i really want to have um
what's the thing that brings me joy for
me it's like i love building things with
with technology i love learning new
things um
there are some parts of the ceo job the
typical ceo job which
you know lower my energy they don't give
me as much energy right there's like you
know frankly like people i'm not the
best people manager in the world right
like um i used to have like 12 direct
reports um at the company and i was like
so stressed and then
now you know now i have like four right
and it's like it's actually much easier
for me to run the company with that so
um
there was a lot of things ideas that i
had in my head i was like well the ceo
has to do that obviously the ceo has to
do that and i sort of let go of some of
those things over time and i said you
know what i'm actually going to focus on
the things that i'm better at because
they bring me joy
and i'm going to delegate a lot of the
stuff which i thought i had to do
and that's actually made the company run
a lot better and it's kept me engaged in
the job like i'm been doing it 10 years
and i hope i can do it another 10 it's
and it's still fun because i've been
able to delegate
why do you have to make that transition
away from fear and maybe insecurity
being the motivator towards it being
about joy and love what what's the cost
if you don't
well i think if you don't then once you
hit some kind of level of success
whatever however people count that
then you're not going to feel motivated
anymore and so you're just you're going
to be done
and uh
you know you're going to go
do whatever else you're going to do next
like i guess become an investor or sit
on the board which is nothing wrong with
that either but i just i d part of me
does wish that more founders were able
to continue being founders and build the
next thing and the next thing
um
i mean
we just met each other barely know each
other but i'm guessing that you're
finding a lot of fulfillment out of like
running this podcast and you sort of
you've you've found some
new level of joy in doing that
so this is like your next founding
moment but
yeah i i think
if you don't do it then you're just
going to burn out it and a lot of people
i think who had some level of success as
a founder they look back on it and they
like well
man i finally got that thing to some
level of success and i sold the company
or whatever
but
i never want to do that again like
because that it damn near killed me and
i was so stressed all the time and so
i've tried to make it i need to get it
to a place where it's fun to run the
company so that i can keep building
companies for many many decades
hopefully that's my goal you're
describing me when you say that so yeah
the company for seven years but it felt
like i was doing it um involved it
wasn't it wasn't voluntary meaningful
struggle it was i can't let this thing
go down yeah it's not i'm not enjoying
it anymore but i can't stop and then at
the point where i realized i could stop
i did immediately in hindsight the way
around that would be to
do a bunch of things involving the you
know how the company's structured and
who owns it who has control and all
those things but really trying to build
a sustainable as you describe it like a
sustainable life for me as a founder and
for my team members yeah
and that
often in silicon valley when especially
when you're in high growth companies
sustainability in terms of culture is
the last thing
how have you done that then how have you
tried to make it sustainable you've
talked about yourself but how have you
how do you create a sustainable company
one that's built for 50 years or 100
well okay so there's a lot of different
elements to that i mean one of them is
just the burnout factor with people
let's talk about that first
um and then i'll come to like repeatable
innovation um
so from a burnout point of view i mean a
few things that i do for instance um
because obviously there's days where you
have to like go hard and sprint and then
um
but for instance like every quarter i
take a week off right i just have that
prescheduled for the year because if you
just kind of wait there's never a good
time to do it
um
we actually tried an experiment this
year where we're having we call them
recharge weeks everybody in the company
is like taking a week off every quarter
and they're doing it at the same time
because
sometimes if you're off you're the only
one who's taking a week off and then
people are pinging you the whole time
and whatever i don't know if we'll keep
doing it or not it's an experiment but
by taking a week off every quarter it
allows me to kind of
make sure that i recharge i have time to
go
um learn new things and it often like
sometimes you know i'm thinking about
the business in some way shape or form
but it's like
yeah that's helped make it sustainable
other things i've done i've had um a lot
of executive coaches different executive
coaches i have one now you know it's
there's different kinds of executive
coaches some of them are very tactical
with their advice like they're former
ceos others are basically therapists
and like you know both are good and
important versions to have um
when i first heard that i was like oh i
don't want the therapist i want like the
tactical ceo coach but you know i've
found the therapist part's almost even
more valuable um let's see what else i
mean
like i have um i have this kind of like
morning routine where like i've noticed
that my days go i'm a lot more stressed
if i just like wake up i look at my
phone you know i haven't really like
had any breakfast or exercise or
anything and like you know i'm like low
blood sugar i just everything's pissing
me off i'm like irritable
um and so that's just a bad way to wake
up since now when i wake up i basically
don't look at my phone you know i try to
like
do the morning routine you know exercise
like
eat some breakfast meditate whatever and
then okay now i'll start my day and like
try to that all these kind of things
help
and i think this is important for the
whole company to some degree because a
lot of new employees especially
like new grads or younger folks like
they they actually don't know about
burnout they'll they'll actually you can
have unlimited vacation policy and tell
people at the all hands meetings
whatever like
don't wait until it's too late you know
take time off but they won't do it like
sometimes i've seen especially high
achieving people they push himself like
too hard
and they'll actually quit and i'm like
why are you quitting and like i'm burned
out and i was like why didn't you take
any vacation the last two years and
they're like
i don't know and they they didn't feel
like they had permission because
everything was so important and so
we're almost like trying to force people
to take a little bit of time off here
and there but
we still have a pretty intense work
environment at coinbase i'm trying to
like
you know amp it up like we we should we
should be going hard but then take
periods of rest and renewal and take
rest like renewal very seriously it's
actually an important skill to learn
so okay so that's kind of how to like
you know go hard for the long term but
don't burn out
um
then i think companies also need to have
repeatable innovation so what that to me
what that means is you can't just be
have like one product
that finally works and then you scale it
and it kind of the s-curve tapers off
and then what do you do i think
companies need to continually have like
a next act you know and a port ideally
like a portfolio of products or
different revenue lines um so that while
something is going down another thing is
going up and
we we do this thing in coinbase called
70 2010 resource allocation so like 70
of our resources go to the core business
today that's making most of the money
and it's at scale 20 of our resources go
towards these adjacent bets that are
like an extension of the core and 10 go
to these venture bets which are
basically like kind of crazy ideas that
have a higher chance of failure but it's
so even in up markets down markets we're
putting 10 percent of our resources
towards
crazy
you know potentially big things that
could work they don't and some of them
don't and that's allowed us to build
this portfolio of products and i think
that's important for the long-term
sustainability of companies because it
always maintains this um
this startup culture this founder
mindset of like
it you know it's it's always day one you
know
never let us become complacent try to
disrupt ourselves before somebody else
does and just keep building the next
thing the next thing the next thing like
that's that's what keeps a company
exciting that's how you extend the
founding moment right like like
zuckerberg is trying to do that now with
with the metaverse instead of just being
a social media company and so
if a company doesn't have like those
continually stretch and try to build the
next thing i think
it just becomes a little more complacent
and like good people eventually leave
and stuff like that every company wants
that at least they say they do yeah but
then they they set up incentive
structures and policies that actually
act as a deterrent for innovation they
disincentivize people to innovate yeah
so a question i get asked a lot when i'm
on stage is you know you've ran an
innovative company in an in an industry
like social media which is changing all
the time and the tricks and tips and
algorithms are adjusting how do you get
your teams to and how do you align
incentives and how do you really make
that philosophy and culture real where
people are actually incentivized to take
risks and to do those those 10
bets that might end up being the the
next aws or the next you know
kindle or whatever in the case of amazon
yeah you're right so i think that it's a
the natural tendency of most orgs is to
not allow that and so you have to
actually fight against it as a founder
or ceo if you have somebody within the
org who is kind of entrepreneurial
and they try something new
and it doesn't work
you know
you have to make sure that that's not
like a black mark on their their career
advancement right there's a difference
between
they had good execution towards the
wrong idea or they had the right idea
but bad execution right if um
like i think uh
you know amazon amazon example right is
like
they tried to launch their own phone at
amazon right near the fire phone and it
was this big failure but my
understanding internally was like
they basically pushed
it was the wrong idea but they had good
execution and so they didn't they didn't
like fire that team because the amazon
phone
failed they said okay the execution was
good you shipped a phone in a pretty
small amount of time
it was toward the wrong idea
let's what next and that i think my
understanding is that team actually
became the kindle team which then was a
very successful product
so um
it's a tolerance for failure recognize
good execution even toward the wrong
idea
um
you know i think some of this has to
come from the founder i don't know i
don't know if there's any other way like
the problem is um
if you look at public companies that
have that are founder-led they actually
like outperform the the rest of the s p
500 and one theory for why that is is
that
this like the scarcest thing inside big
companies is actually risk tolerance
um and so founders can kind of provide
that now you can
you if you can go too far with this
right you we know of founders who have
too much risk tolerance and have kind of
blown the place up right we work yeah
exactly
and then we also know of companies that
had you know like not enough risk
tolerance they had a professional ceo
come in
you know i don't want to criticize
anybody but like like
steve ballmer or someone would be a
classic example i'm sure he's a smart
guy right but something happened there
where they didn't have the risk
tolerance
so
i kind of view my job as like a founder
ceo at this point is to ensure we have
um enough risk tolerance to try new
ideas and then i and then i also want to
pair myself with
great operators like like emily choi our
ceo and president right and we have a
really amazing executive team so
it's the combination of like great
operator but also great founder energy
which i think is a nice combination that
creates
good outcomes if you do if you're too
heavy on one or the other sometimes it
doesn't work as well
there's something a lot of you don't
know about me last year i co-founded a
company called third web and most of my
available time right now is spent
building third web so
what is third web third web makes it
really really easy to build web through
applications and today's guest is one of
the most famous ceos and founders in
web3 and we actually have a really
strong relationship with his company
coinbase so it felt somewhat fitting to
introduce third web to you in this
episode just for a couple of seconds
since we launched third web the growth
has been insane the world's biggest
brands sports teams creators gaming
studios and hundreds of funded web3
startups have all used third web to
power everything that they want to do in
web 3. nft drops packs dowels you name
it third web powers it in the last two
months alone the number of active
projects using third web tools has
doubled despite the bear market so if
you're an entrepreneur if you're a brand
owner if you're a web 3 developer or
just someone that's interested in web 3
which is in my opinion the next major
technological shift that will impact all
of our lives kind of like social media
and web 2 did then you can start
building that future today using third
web check out thirdweb.com for more the
link is in the description below
let's get back to the episode
you read this um the white paper
satoshi's famous bitcoin white paper
pivotal moment for you sparks interest
and intrigue while you're at um airbnb
you do something which a lot of people
ask me about as well which is when
you're in a job and you have a spark of
inspiration how do you do both you've
got to pay the bills on one end but then
you want to pursue this idea how did you
do both because you stayed at airbnb
while you started developing yeah what
became coinbase
yeah so basically i did it on nights and
weekends people didn't like that answer
yeah it sounds toxic it required a lot
of energy i mean i basically so
so first of all you need to make sure
that if you are currently employed like
don't build it you know on company hours
and don't build it on the company laptop
there's a lot of um
ip litigation that has ended you know
for some people has ended badly because
the company actually owns it typically
at least in the us i don't know what the
rules are in other countries
um if you build it on employ on company
time on the company hardware the company
probably owns the ip
so you need to make sure you're doing it
on your own computer not during hours so
anyway i i would often work till like 7
p.m or something like that i'd come home
eat dinner or something like that and
then i would work from like 8 p.m to
midnight
um i would do that maybe three or four
days a week on weekdays and then on the
weekend i'd work
maybe like sunday afternoon for like
seven or eight hours so i was i was
probably doing like 20 hours a week or
something like that on
what would eventually become coinbase in
my personal time and it was hard it
sucked i mean i was like tired after a
full day of work it's like 7 p.m but
this is where that some of that
determination comes in right and i was
like
okay well my co-workers like going out
drinking or whatever and
nothing wrong with that i did a lot
plenty of that but like in my time at
that moment in that time i was i was you
know my late 20s i was like i really
want to try to build something important
in the world like i'm going to have to
take
like
my own
determination and turn that into this
fuel to go try to build this thing so
i probably did that for like a year year
and a half to try to build the prototype
of what would become coinbase
um and then i applied to y combinator
they they eventually accepted me and
wrote me the initial seed check that's
what gave me the confidence to quit my
job and go full time on it how did you
maintain friendships and those kind of
meaningful personal relationships at
that in that time when you're working
full-time during the day and then coming
home and writing
code
where's the
you know where's the time for
friends and girlfriends and yeah
i was pretty intense about it i i would
say i sacrificed uh
friendships for it i mean it's not like
i wasn't like you know um
just like never responding to people but
people would ping me like hey can you
come out and this thing and i was like
actually i remember it's a funny memory
one time this guy who i really like um
from work he was he's like come out to
this thing we're going to this club or
something
and i think i literally wrote back to
him
i'm changing the world one line of code
at a time
can't hang out he's like rock on i love
it
um
so you know i was joking or whatever
with my mom yeah
so
you know i think i've seen this happen
to various people like they they get to
a certain point in their life and like
god damn it i'm gonna [ __ ] can i swear
on this program of course you can okay
so anyway there's a there comes a time
i've seen this happen to various people
in their life it's something triggers it
sometimes it's like
it's an age thing they're like turning a
certain age where they always thought
they would have more done by then or
they
you know a certain maybe someone in
their family passes away and they're
like oh my god like time is finite it's
precious
and something happens where they're like
i'm not gonna [ __ ] around anymore like
i'm gonna get this done
no matter the cost and they just start
really buckling down they find this
source of energy and so
you know
find whatever that is for for you like
the listener out there and um
and then go hard at it you know finish
your book like launch your
launcher thing whatever it is the app
the startup just just start doing stuff
like and even if you don't even know
what to do just do anything because you
know action will produce information
um
i i actually so that you just reminded
me there was a precursor to the coinbase
which was um this app that i built with
my friend uh which we were trying to
figure out how bitcoin worked and we
built that and the minute we shipped it
i was like it's built wrong
and i knew the architecture was wrong
and then i knew what to do next and so
oftentimes you don't even know what to
do just do anything and you'll find
it'll help you get to the right thing
action leads to information yeah action
produces information
never heard that before i i i stole that
from uh paul graham i think who started
white commentators yeah it's so true and
i will steal that from you so again can
you hear that in the future without
credit then you know where it's come
from at that time what were you trying
to build you'd read that white paper you
launched that first step then after that
first app you launched what were you
trying to build what was the vision
yeah so this was 2000 um i guess it was
like 2010 time frame and you howled i
guess i was like 29 yeah something like
that
um
so what i was trying to do i had read
the bitcoin white paper and i was like
okay this is a decentralized protocol
for money or something
and my
thought in my head at that time was well
there's been other decentralized
protocols like email is a decentralized
protocol
you know git is a tool that developers
used for version control and so for
email people didn't really run their own
email servers they'd use a hosted email
service like gmail or forget they'd use
a hosted service like github right so my
thought was okay here's a new
decentralized protocol people are going
to need like a github or a gmail type
thing that does all the security in the
backups for you and it works on mobile
and the web and i was like someone's
going to build a company doing that
would be kind of a hard company to run
because you're going to be storing all
this bitcoin people are going to want to
hack it and like that's not like a
weekend project that's like a really
serious
responsibility
and i was
had that idea in the back of my head and
somehow i couldn't get it out of my head
and so i just sort of like started
tinkering with
i i wasn't even really just
saying i was going to build a company
yet i was more like um
i don't know let me just try building a
prototype of this to see what if again
action produces information
and so
that was the original idea it was it was
like a hosted bitcoin wallet instead of
like running your own one on your on
your own computer with a node and
everything was just complicated at the
time and when you told people this idea
what was their reaction because you
would have had to tell a lot of people
that you were building this
thing with this thing called bitcoin on
a
other thing which they wouldn't have
understood either yeah so people didn't
get it at all i talked to some of my
smartest friends
about it
and they were like i don't really get
this bitcoin thing it sounds like a scam
honestly right so that they didn't that
was not reassuring
um and then i went to a couple bitcoin
meetups people who were really into
bitcoin and i was like yeah i'm building
like a hosted bitcoin well like gmail
for email but
and i remember one of these people was
like that's a terrible idea because
um you know all the people try to do
that they get hacked and they lose they
lose all the customer funds and so like
that's you should never do that right so
i didn't get a lot of positive feedback
everybody i talked to actually thought
that audio was a bad idea
um even when i was i had gone through y
combinator i was trying to raise money
um
you know i would say like for every
10 meetings i did with investors i got
nine no's and one kind of
i guess like small yes
so
and that's always tough like fundraising
is always tough but you know if you go
to these people who you believe are like
really smart people
and 90 of them are telling you no
that's like that's like the best case
scenario in my experience um
you know the the worst case scenario is
100 of them tell you no so but either
way it's like 90 90 of people telling
you you have to be really
kind of willing to um not get
discouraged by that
you had a co-founder for a couple of
weeks during that y combinator process
right yeah
i heard that you um
in in applying for y combinator you
wanted to have a co-founder you met
someone quickly and then it didn't last
more than like four weeks or something
yeah exactly um yeah so i was looking
for a co-founder at that time and um
ben reeves had created this really good
app called blockchain.info at the time
now it's blockchain.com but
um
so i reached out to him we didn't really
know each other that well we ended up
applying to white combinator and uh
sort of did this like shotgun wedding
thing but it didn't it didn't work out
and it was like
we were about to start the program and
um
we basically decided to part ways so
it's funny in an alternate universe
um
blockchain.com and coinbase would have
been the same company but anyway
it all obviously worked out well for
both of us
did you have self-doubt at that point
for sure oh man i was filled with
self-doubt yeah
i
i thought
that first of all i thought maybe i was
crazy because all my friends who i
talked about this idea thought it was
a bad idea
um the thing that gave me a glimmer of
hope was that y combinator decided to
give me this 150k seed check and i
really respected y combinator um so that
gave me a big shot of confidence but
you know before that it was like
it was very touch and go i mean i i was
like well my co-founder thing didn't
work out um
i don't know like i'm just going to try
my best here but like this i was like
this has like a pretty high chance of
failure what did your parents think
um okay so my parents have always have
people who worked at like big companies
like their whole life and um
i don't know if they ever really got the
whole entrepreneurship thing that i was
so into
the
when i called to tell them that i was
quitting airbnb to go start this company
there was kind of like okay well
we we support you we love you like
are you gonna have any health insurance
that's what my mom asked i think
um
and so i think there was
they were kind of afraid that i was
doing something really stupid and
reckless
is my guess
but
they ultimately trusted me and supported
it probably probably with a lot of
doubts
is my guess on that point of co-founders
yeah um i read that you eventually sort
of interviewed 50 odd co-founders to try
and find the right one for what would
become coinbase
what were you looking for
and what was in hindsight what advice
would you give me because that's another
question i get asked a lot is how did
you find a co-founder and yeah
so yeah i was looking for a co-founder
at that time desperately and i was i'd
go on these like co-founders dates you
know we'd meet somebody see how it goes
they'd pitch you your their startup idea
i'd tell them about mine and maybe go on
a second date or third date so
none of these seem to like really click
and i guess i was looking for someone to
get really excited about my idea
um but also somebody who i felt was
really complementary to me in terms of
like um it pushed me to think bigger and
stuff like that i hadn't thought about
before and you know i wanted to leave
feeling energized and that i'd learned
something
and they were good compliment
and so
i got kind of disillusioned because a
number of these went on and on and on
and i could i couldn't find anybody like
that i really liked to join this thing
so eventually i just got fed up
and i was like all right you know what
i'm just gonna do this thing on my own
and like
and get it off the ground
and
lo and behold once i started to show
some signs of progress you know like
getting through y combinator raising a
seed check getting the product i put the
prototype out there on like reddit and
the right person reached out to me
and so anyway i tell people that story
because i think it's an important lesson
which is basically
if you don't have the right co-founder
just keep making progress and signs of
success may cause the right person to
find you it needs to be public signs of
success it's almost like putting out the
bat signal
like um if you have like half of an idea
you can't just like
be talking to your friends about it you
got to put it out on a blog post or like
a prototype or get something out there
in the world on twitter or whatever
because then the other person might be
out there and they won't know to find
you and reach out unless you put out the
bat signal so
that's also really good dating advice
it's like you said if you don't have a
co-founder just keep making progress and
putting it out there
i guess it's true like in terms of
people fitness and you know health and
development fine figure out yourself
yeah exactly yeah and you become a
magnet as opposed to having to be a
peacock
that's true so
and that's much more valuable when i
think about your first tutoring company
there was that pivotal moment where you
removed the payment and just kind of got
out the way and that was pivotal to the
company exploding yeah when you think
about those early years what what was
the significant step that unlocked the
the growth in your view
yeah so there was a significant moment
like that with coinbase too because
oftentimes by the way
the first version of a product you put
out it doesn't work in fact that's the
only thing i've ever seen happen in
startups i've never i've never seen a
startup there the very first version of
their product actually worked sometimes
in hindsight people like to tell that
story but
i think in reality it's very rare
so for us or for really it was just me
initially then that was fred ursum and i
co-founding it um
the first version was this hosted
bitcoin wallet and so we had i i posted
on reddit some people would sign up but
nobody would stick around and use the
product
so in y commentary they teach you this
great thing which is
don't spend your time you know like
going to conferences and like trying to
raise money it's like if you don't have
product market fit yet
talk to your customers and then improve
the product based on their feedback and
then talk to your customers and improve
the product talk to customers improve
the product there's really only two
things you should be doing in the early
stage talking to your customers and
improving the product sounds like simple
advice but people spend so much time
doing other stuff
that's actually not real work so
taking this advice
i emailed you know
10 of the people or so who had signed up
for the product and never come back
and i said hey i created this app like
i'd love to get on the phone with you
and just talk to you about it for a
minute so i remember i got on the phone
with some of these people
and one of them one of them was like
you know what do you think about the app
he's like well i kind of i kind of like
it but i don't have any bitcoin so i
just didn't come back and i remember
thinking
well if there had been
an easy way to get bitcoin into your
wallet like a buy button or something
like would you have stuck around and
used it he's like yeah probably
and so i was like okay let me go try to
make a simple buy button so when people
sign up they can actually get some
bitcoin into their wallet and it turned
out that was a very hard thing to do you
had to get these bank partnerships i had
to figure out money transmission
licenses and i won't bore you with all
the details there was a lot of
you know
making things work somehow behind the
scenes
but the minute that we that we launched
at that time i think frederson had just
joined we launched that um that buy
button
it started to grow every day organically
with no marketing or anything and that
was the minute i felt like we finally
had private market fit
over the next let's say five so that's
2012 roughly 2012. over the next five
years up until the point where fred
departs that growth is
pretty crazy right for coinbase
yeah i mean it started growing
organically um
and
we had a very good problem at that point
which was that um we were basically
every time someone clicked the buy
button we had to use our own capital to
acquire the bitcoin at that right at
that price so we didn't have some
exposure to it going up or down and then
we would initiate a debit to their bank
account and two or three business days
later we'd get the funds so we had
basically had a working capital issue
like we were using our own corporate
funds to buy the crypto and then getting
their money the payment from the
customer
and the numbers started to go up and up
and up and um i think it raised like
600k at that time and we were using like
550k to service the day-to-day buying on
the site
and so
we realized quite quickly we're like
okay we need to go out and raise money
and that was a good a good a good story
to raise money was hey this thing is
growing so fast that
we we're going to be turning away
business if we don't raise money that's
a good story to go raise money as
opposed to you know the numbers are kind
of flat we haven't really got it working
yet so i think it was very important
that we we found product market fit only
when we couldn't scale then we went out
to raise capital what mistakes did you
make as a company in those first five
years that you in hindsight go damn
that's a that's a key learning
yes i think if i were to go back and do
it again there's a few things i might
have
done that would have helped it be more
get to get there even more efficiently i
mean
one is that we actually never wrote down
like the mission of the company or the
value of the company early on
and we were doing it all organically we
were basically just hiring interviewing
every single person who would join and
we managed to create this really
interesting culture but it was a little
bit
it wasn't very deliberate it was just it
happened kind of accidentally because we
were just choosing the people that we
wanted to work with and we really
surprised us and we're really bright
in those high growth moments there's so
things keep breaking yeah and processors
actually need to adopt when you get as
you'll know from when you go from a
couple of people to them 50 to 100 to
them so just thinking if there's any
advice you have for me someone i've
grown a business but not in not in such
a a high growth way and not in such an
interesting um
uncharted industry
um
eventually your co-founder fred departs
what was that like emotionally because i
can't imagine the thought of my
co-founder parting in e5 it would almost
make me feel honestly it would have made
me feel like
they were part of the reason i was doing
this yeah you know that bond and that
we're in this together so how did that
feel emotionally
i mean it was awful um
i cried
you know um
so
yeah so i think
here's the whole story so i think really
fred um president was an amazing
co-founder and we were building all this
great stuff together he's really a
natural leader right and so
um i was the ceo of the company but
there was times where you know i i think
he felt like he was being held back he
really kind of wanted to run his own
thing at a certain point and we were
almost kind of like running it jointly
at various places and at various times
and so i tried my best to like keep him
engaged and i was like all right why
don't you go do all the external facing
stuff and what's the thing that would
really excite you like you know
he did a lot of the fundraising like he
was really representing the company in
the way you know the the titles didn't
matter
um
but ultimately i think he really did
want to run his own thing and so he was
very clear with me he we talked about it
basically over the period of like a year
or so um
with an exec coach and all this and
one of the things that i think i'm most
proud of is that he and i are still like
really good friends probably best
friends to this day
um whereas a lot of co-founders when
someone does leave there's a blow up and
it's like i think we both realized at a
certain point it was like actually the
more important thing to preserve here is
the friendship and so
he was great about it he was like i want
to make sure the company's in a good
place it doesn't need to happen any
there's nothing soon here happening but
i do eventually want to transition so
over a period of a year we talked about
it and then when he finally told me he
was ready i cried
um
it did feel like you know it was losing
kind of half the company the the s
founding moment of it and i remember so
then we had to go in front of the
company and tell deliver the news
oh man so
um
we talked to the board and everything
like that too first but we went i
remember the day we had to go
tell the company
and you know
i i wasn't normally i wasn't getting
nervous talking to the company like you
know first company's two people and then
it's five then it's 10 and then it's 50
then it's 100 200 so you sort of get to
build up your tolerance and like okay i
could go talk to the company of 150
people or something
but this time i had to go up there and
tell them the co-founder was leaving and
i remember i went up in for the company
and my voice
cracked like i was like a
14 year old 13 year old whatever and
then my my leg was like shaking you know
sometimes you get like enough adrenaline
if you're like you're nervous that
you're just like you're anyway i was
like oh my god it's so embarrassing like
i had to like walk behind the podium so
nobody could see my leg shaking and my
voice is cracking
and i'm like god i'm [ __ ] i'm messing
this up you know like because i'm
supposed to be projecting confidence and
like no it's not a big deal we're gonna
get through this and i'm just like
coming across like this pre-pubescent
kid you know
um
so everybody of course is like kind of
shocked and they could
people were like i could tell you were
really scared brian i was like [ __ ] okay
i didn't really announce that very well
um and of course like you know
48 hours went by like
everybody
freaked out and then it was like 40
hours later it was like all right let's
get back to work you know and and of
course it wasn't as bad as i thought but
yeah that was a really scary moment and
then and basically i had to transition
from
running the company with like all right
fred and i let's get in the room and
decide it to okay let's actually build
an executive team around me um
to
have a more like professionally run
company if you will so it ended up being
like sort of a second founding moment of
the company and i realized this later
actually companies have many founding
moments
and you can just keep building what
situation was the company and now again
in hindsight yeah at that stage because
i heard in 2017 things were a little bit
messy
and and you brought in this executive
team to kind of help you you know
solve some of those problems but when at
the point when fred left
what was the state of the company
so he he left it as this market was
swinging up and that was conscious on
his part he wanted to make sure the
company didn't harm the company as he
left
um
and so yeah the challenge after that was
like okay go build an exec team and a
lot of founders have gotten through this
it's
it's quite hard so
if the company is growing you know 50 a
year or something you can oftentimes
promote people from within who are kind
of learning on the job and just take on
more and more responsibility
we in the in these cryptos so volatile
to go through like 500 growth in one
year and then
negative 100 the next year and it's like
so
i felt like i was in over my head like
all these junior people who had joined
early on we were all in over our head we
were like so we basically went out to
seek more experienced executives to come
in
and um that was in itself its own
crazy process with lots of learnings
because
whenever you bring in a bunch of
high-powered executives you know
sometimes you get people who butt heads
right and um it's hard when like taking
a new team
they have to build trust and oftentimes
the team is often like kind of
dysfunctional until like they go through
enough together so
we had some good blow-ups there um there
was some executives like left or were
fired and like um
you know i had to like basically learn
how to work with with more
seasoned executives
and people who had run massive things
before and um
you know i i guess one lesson i learned
from that and this is kind of personal
to me there's different people find
different things that work for them but
you know i realized i wanted to work
with people who were not just really
brilliant but like also really humble
because i'm not really like a combative
person by nature like some people
some companies have this culture where
they love to hash things out and debate
it and like that's that's like a really
good conversation or like you kind of
get into it you're like
you know but i'm i'm more of like i want
to think about what you said and like
come back and and more collaborative so
i'm not really i'm a little bit conflict
diverse
so um anyway i started hiring more for
like people who are bright but humble
collab collaborative i mean the risk of
that by the way is you can get into a
little bit of like a yes person culture
where every everyone's afraid to
disagree or something that's also not
good but
it took me a couple iterations to kind
of find my style there and
now it's working great like the exec
team is super
competent and high trust and
collaborative
and i think it's like a it gives us a
lot of
benefits as a company because there's
like basically no bs politics stuff it's
just like we're just getting work done
have each other's back
and we have you have to constantly tend
that and nurture it like with these exec
offsides and stuff but
yeah there were some learning pains
there when when crypto went through that
first well not the first but that real
that sort of 2017 bull run where
everything was going up how were you
feeling as the ceo of coinbase coinbase
is exploding i remember that that's when
i i first downloaded coinbase and became
a coinbase customer how were you feeling
a ceo in terms of
optimism for
how long that moment was going to last
did you did you have a suspicion that it
that in 2018 i believe it was that the
market would come crashing down
yeah i didn't know when it would happen
but there was definitely
it it tipped at a certain point from
like oh this growth is really good too
okay things are getting a little crazy
here like
there was
yeah i remember i'd go to some events
and i was like everybody was coming in
launching some ico
and um people would like come over and
like want to take selfies with me and
then like post the stuff on twitter and
like almost implying i was like
endorsing the project and then um i
remember like weird stuff happened like
i was living in this apartment building
in san francisco
and this guy who like worked in the
building
came to me one day and he's like this
package arrived for you sir and uh sir i
just have this question like which
crypto should i buy and i was like i
don't know this is getting really weird
like i don't i don't give any investment
advice or whatever and
um
yeah so basically it started attracting
in like people who are just trying to
get rich quick or scams and all this
stuff
and so
yeah we started i started walking around
with like a security guard um
we had like some over exuberant
customers it was it was weird tell me
about that because
i was i was thinking we've had some um
fintech ceos here yeah that have built
disruptive banks out in europe so monzo
starling bank et cetera even clark you
know klan i guess that's not a bank but
kleiner the ceo sebastian here as well
security is not something that most ceos
have to think about but when you're
dealing with money
as tom told me from monzo you get a lot
of
unhappy people because you're
you know you sometimes you have to
freeze funds and things like that
yeah well okay so i think
i mean if at a certain size of company
it's almost inevitable for every ceo
it's not just it's just not just money
but i do think that we probably started
a little earlier
because um because it was crypto is
money
um
and yeah i mean it's it's also just a
law of numbers like if you're running an
enterprise a sas a b2b business
something like that you might have
thousands of customers or maybe 100 000
or something but if you're running a
very popular consumer app
um and you get into the millions or you
know coinbase has like maybe like 100
million ish verified users now
um
if you just think about it statistically
i mean you know
like what like one in a hundred people
in society has some form of
schizophrenia right
maybe one one out of ten of those like
so one out of a thousand people in
society
has a form of mental illness that just
like
you know
could be potentially dangerous or they
can become obsessed with things
irrationally or whatever and so if you
have 100 million customers like there's
going to be enough people as part of it
is just like a law of large numbers
but um
you know i i don't want to overstate it
like it's not i don't it's not like a
huge burden on my life i i feel i feel
safe and i'm able to keep functioning
and stuff like that
um
yeah another thing most ceos don't have
to contend with is building a business
in such a volatile market so when in
2018 the market comes crashing down the
crypto market comes crashing down
talk to me about what leadership lessons
you learned through that what would what
i can only imagine
as being a pretty awful period
yeah so 2018 everything was coming down
off that high of 2017
and you know i had been through a couple
cycles like this but each one was
getting bigger and bigger and
it was tough i mean i in the following i
think year or so after that crash i
think we might have had like 25 of the
company leave or something right really
yeah so there is a lot of attrition
there were people who had joined and
they thought hey this is a rocket ship
it's only going one way and then
when it was down and lots of negative
news headlines come along you know the
news always focuses on things that are
not always but often focuses on things
that are too short-term when it's going
up they're like this is they're genius
and their future everything's future and
then when it's down they're like this is
never gonna it's failed and neither one
is true right like reality you have to
zoom out to kind of look at reality
but one thing i realized um was that i
felt this overwhelming pressure as ceo
was like oh shoot like every every week
i've got to get in from the company and
like put on a good face
and like create some sense of optimism
right
the reality was
i was kind of feeling shitty about it
too and so it was a little inauthentic
for me to go up there and
try to just be super positive or
something and so one leadership lesson i
learned during that moment is that
great leaders are often vulnerable
and so
it's actually a much more powerful
leadership uh style i think to just go
up there and say how you actually feel
which you might be able to go you might
go up there and say something like i
feel like [ __ ] today you know like this
thing's down like this person quit
um whatever it is
now it helps if you if you can then use
that to as a moment to like
bring the team together and it's not
like you have to solve all the problems
as ceo it's like
we
you use a lot of we language right it's
like i don't know how you're feeling i
feel like this that that's going to take
a little bit of attention out of the
room because they're all probably
feeling it too and they're like okay
great this guy's like not a robot he
like kind of gets it too it's like okay
so what can we do about it like well we
all need to figure out how to solve x x
is a pretty big problem right now we all
need to figure out how to solve y so
what do w what are we going to do like
this week i'm going to host this meeting
with so and so in this group and like
we're going to come i want you to all
bring your best ideas about how we're
going to solve x we're going to pick one
and we're going to double down on it
right so now now it's like you're
turning this authenticity this candor
in and you're and you're making
everybody a part of the solution it's
not like
hey everybody look to brian like
he's got all the answers you know this
like messiah complex or whatever like no
it's like the strength is comes from the
team it's not just like
me trying to carry the whole weight of
the world in my shoulders or something
so that that was a good leadership
lesson for me
how did you do you've been through you
know these crypto winters and your
company got so big that you know it went
public and then when you become a public
company and you're almost seen as the
poster child
of this space in many respects at least
that's that's always been my view of
coinbase there's been many many
exchanges but the the number one one the
one that's the famous one the
the poster child is coinbase
the pressure
and the scrutiny and the headlines and
the f and the the fake news and all of
it yeah that you must be have thrown at
you and then all the you know the
internal problems of just running a
business anyway how are you dealing with
your emotions
yeah okay wow deep question so um
let's see i think
because you're human yeah of course
okay so i think one of the most
important things i i totally didn't
realize this before starting a company
but it turns out
one of the most important things um
skill sets to kind of
develop as a ceo of a startup is that
you have to be willing to ignore
a lot of noise um both positive and
negative right
because if people on the way up are
telling you how brilliant you are and
you kind of get caught up in like
going to the speaker circuit and like
you know um then
you're going to fall even harder when
they turn on you and then everybody
either gets built up or taken down and
it's just driving headlines right so
you kind of can't believe it on the way
up because then you won't believe it on
the way down either
um i totally didn't realize that by
starting a company i thought most people
would generally be rooting for you and
you know
um but there's people out there rooting
for you to fail which is a weird thing
um they're kind of dealing with their
own maybe stuff about success right i
don't know what it is
um
but you have to learn how to just tune
all that out so i mean like
frankly i just don't don't read like a
lot of news anymore i kind of think of
it like sugar it's it's addictive
and can you consume it in small
quantities responsibly and like eat a
couple bites of dessert or something
like yes
but um you have to be really careful
because
basically the kind of um anger fear
outrage whatever you know is an
addictive thing by the way it's not just
mainstream media like social media has
some challenges with this too right i
i think it's actually a little
hypocritical like mainstream media is
always criticizing social media for
misinformation and it's like it's
pot calling the kiddo black or whatever
it's like the same thing happening there
so i literally try not to read a lot of
this stuff
so once then once you developed
your own sort of
psychology about it now you have to
insulate the team from it because
they'll go after your team
and um so you need to kind of
continually be preaching this to the
team about like
you know be an independent thinker right
go
develop your own source of truth like
um by going to the root of it like um
don't
don't be listening to um mainstream
media or social media whatever when
things are up or down
you have to curate you have to
use that stuff in moderation like like
sugar or something it's not actually
they're they're trying to sell their own
product and they're and
one of my friends has this great saying
um
it's like only a half truth can go viral
like if it's
you know that
triggering or whatever that's like ah
like it goes all around the world it's
it's half true at best
and so you have to remember that
whenever you see anything out there
what are the things that still penetrate
all of that resilience though there's
because there's things in even me that i
i i understand all of that um as i was
saying to you before we start recording
i became a dragon dragon's den so i got
much more scrutiny than i've ever got
from headlines i'd read about my family
that i don't have my girlfriend i'd done
this that
you'd think i was running guantanamo bay
the way that right they described my
former business all these things um
and although i knew i was resilient and
although i knew everything you've said
and i put these processes in place where
i don't see notifications someone tweets
me i probably don't even see it it
doesn't come up never read the replies
yeah i don't have that i turned off all
notifications too that's that's a really
good one like but what pierces you still
yeah what still moves your mood
so there's def there's something every
year at least that like it's the next
level that it's gonna test you right
and um
you know
oh man what was most recently um there
was like i don't even know if this was
real or if this was like short sellers
like putting fake information out there
but there was some like petition that um
some employees put together or something
and like i saw your response to yeah i
got irritated by it and like wrote some
stuff on twitter about it but that that
bugged me for a bit because it was like
um
okay like you're going to attack the
executives like it's not even their
fault like you you know whatever blame
me so
um
i think what there's always something
new it's like
you know a lot of people probably would
be okay with oh there's some somebody
saying something stupid on twitter or
whatever but they really respect x you
know maybe it's like
um the new york times or something or
whatever right and they're like oh
that's that's like a and so then you get
your first like negative article like
that has false information in it in the
new york times and then you're like well
that just shattered my reality of like
even that could happen like so man and
there's like what else is
like not accurate in the new york times
or pic pick any other you know fox news
like whatever
you know even one of the ones that
really got to me was um
i always felt like okay we have these
kind of people who are upset with us
outside of the company but the company
is one team like we're all and then when
i started to see like sometimes there
were people in the company kind of
turning on each other i was like man
that one really bugged me right
so
think about um
if you think about
companies that have gotten to really big
scale
it makes all your problems look small by
comparison okay like like look at mark
zuckerberg right i mean the amount of
negative news coming out on that guy on
a daily basis
right
um
i think that
like the russian government like just
put him on some like
um
list of like sanctioned people or
something like there's people of
tons of death threats you know like
um
there's there's always another level i
can get to
you know that's just like
anyway i i
what i've realized about a lot of
people who i think are building
important things in the world is that
they've developed this like high
disagreeableness muscle
where
they've recognized like they're not
going to make everybody happy and
they've made peace with it right
so they realize at a certain point like
whether i do the thing that i think
everyone's going to like or everything
that
is more authentic to me someone's going
to be pissed no matter what so at the
end of the day i'm just going to do the
thing that i think is the right thing
and they they've leaned more into
authenticity instead of trying to say
what they think people want to hear
and that does require you to have some
amount of thick skin some kind of high
disagreeableness and then they can
actually
do even more interesting stuff because
they're they're being themselves instead
of trying to be liked
my success and my building my personal
brand and getting millions of followers
online
it scratched that itch in an unhealthy
way that we described earlier it kind of
made me feel it gave me external
validation which felt like it was
filling me up it's probably sugar or
something
and then the problem is if you if you
were that type of person when you when
you do reach that height you get more
public scrutiny it matters more to you
because validation was your driving
force this whole time yeah so is there
an element of that with you because
because you were an introvert that
wanted to have significant be
significant because of that early
upbringing that it might be
psychologically more difficult to deal
with because significance and fitting in
i guess was so
paramount to your initial motivation
totally yeah i mean it can be very
it can be very addictive also just to be
liked and and
the adulation and everything so
the minute something starts to happen
that you realize people aren't going to
like you for your temptation is to try
to preserve it now you have something to
lose you're like i'm going to lose these
followers or i'm going to you know
um
whatever it does it doesn't even matter
but it always feels serious at the time
so
i i definitely had to grow through that
i i don't know i think i'm still growing
through that to i i would like to get to
a place where
you know you don't want you don't want
to become like isolated to a place where
you're not listening to anybody because
that's also really bad so you you do
wanna you need people who can keep you
grounded like your family like your
friends whatever and people who around
you who will tell you when you're being
an idiot or you're just wrong so like
you don't ever wanna get to a place
where i listen to nobody right but
a lot of people you want to be around
people who have your best interests at
heart and then listen to them or people
have already done what you're trying to
do it like listen that's good advice but
a lot of the people who are just trying
to take shots at you to build their own
whatever in life
you need to build the ability to ignore
them and um
it's a real superpower to like care less
what other people think
um at least people who don't have your
best interests at heart having worked in
social media over the last 10 years i
maybe in my seventh or eighth year
noticed a really interesting thing that
happened um organizations as end women
say in their trust reports were once
black boxes which is the reputation of
the organization the image was written
on the outside of the black box of the
organization by the marketing department
of pr we moved into this world where
they're now glass boxes the world can
see inside all of your employees have
smartphones and they can take pictures
and write reviews and so organizations
now um had to adapt and one of the
things that i've seen just as an
observation is ceos being out there in
the public eye
overly out there in the public eye i'm
thinking elon yeah and the antithesis of
that might be zuckerberg who basically
hid for 10 years and the media shaped
him as a
soulless data stealing robot and then
you've got elon because he's smoking
weed on durogan's podcast you can say
whatever you like about him i think i
know him
right i have my own reference point and
my point here is about transparency and
even doing things like this
for me i don't i don't know how you feel
about this but for me the if i was
running a big organization
i'd be doing a lot to make sure that the
public had their own reference point of
who i am
how does that all sit with you because
that seems to be the only defense
against the media
writing your narrative yeah so i've
thought about this a lot and i'm not
sure i have the perfect answer but um
so i think there's a spectrum so
on one side of the spectrum like you
said you can actually zuckerberg is
somewhere in the middle to me but
to be truly isolated i think like larry
page for instance he was very reclusive
almost never gave interviews right
elon is kind of out there doing a lot
more interviews and he's just like
literally says whatever he thinks i
think you know right on twitter did you
see zuckerberg's 2019 facebook post
which one he did the post i think was
2019 maybe 2017 that sounds better 2017
he did a post saying that he's basically
hidden away for that whole period of
time his new year's resolution was to
come out of his bunker so he did a
period of um hiding out and like yeah
yeah
so i mean i think a lot of ceos struggle
with this because
you know i think a lot of people realize
like it sucks to be famous
so
you know when i was a kid i would you'd
hear people say that or something and
i'd be like yeah whatever for you to say
but um
there's a lot of downsides right i mean
people
in the the media or publicity can be
like this this cruel beast right if you
feed it it just wants more and more and
more so
um
i think
there are advantages to having a public
profile like it helps you recruit people
if someone attacks the company you have
your own direct audience to like get the
the message out the truth so there's
definitely like benefits
and then there's drawbacks because now
you know maybe your kids need security
or whatever or just um
you know someone's gonna come up to your
restaurant when you're trying to have a
thing with your family or whatever
so there's real downsides to it um
i think for me i'm trying to find this
reasonable middle ground where like i i
turn down
95 of media
um
i i really want to talk to people like
that are doing what new media right like
like this like podcasts or um or youtube
or really just have conversations with
people that i think are interesting and
i like
um
that get messages out in sort of unique
ways
and i i do i like having some amount of
following if i ever need to set the
record on something but i don't want to
become famous actually i'd rather if i
could avoid that
i would prefer it
i think it's it's sort of a acceptable
negative of building something
interesting in the world but it's not
it's not actually a positive
interesting and one of the things you
talked about was that um
who knows whether it was real or not
there was a
i want to give context to the listeners
who don't who don't follow you and might
not have seen that there was a uh
something written up that said
internally an employee was petitioning
to have someone else removed internally
yeah whether it's true or not we don't
know it was taken down um you responded
to that on twitter yeah you also said to
me that you were
in a bit of a bad mood when you
responded to that twitter yeah how do
you feel in hindsight about all of that
and did you
did you learn anything about company
culture or changes that needed to be
made or give me your reflections on that
yeah so
you never know if you're doing the right
thing right um
one argument would be that this is just
unnecessary i could have ignored it and
um
there was people who never even saw it
and there was and they read my tweets
and they were like oh what's going on
and now i gave even more attention to it
right yeah
um on the flip side there was a bunch of
people who reached out to me that was
very positive it was like i'm glad
you're just
you know saying it like it is like it
shows who you really what you really
care about
and um you're basically communicating to
the rest of employees like if you're
unhappy about something like there's a
right forum to do that internally it's
not
this is harming the company and so
you're anyway a lot of people liked it
some people didn't like it at all
so did i do the right thing i have no
idea i'm just like making this up as i
go and i kind of i kind of like try
things and i see how they go
one thing i will say is that
something that's polarizing is not that
doesn't make it
the wrong thing to do it what makes it
to me the right thing to do the wrong
thing to do is whether it was
authentically true
um so i don't know how i would do it
again next time i guess i maybe i would
do it with a cool head
and um
see if it still felt authentic and then
go from there polarizing another thing
that when people talk about company
culture people give
um people that i've been around point to
coinbase as an example of is you coming
out and saying that coinbase wouldn't
uh tolerate politics
um and other divisive topics being
discussed on company channels in the
workplace yeah this is a big conv i've
had conversations this week with my
companies where they've talked about
coinbase and the example you've set
because of things that have happened
over the last couple of weeks in
politics around in america
um
tell me why you made that decision
because i once upon a time when we had
brexit in this company allowed my office
to get overrun with anti-brexit flags
and i actually regret that because a
week later an employee pulled me aside
and said i'm actually pro-brexit and the
whole week i felt like the office wasn't
a safe place for me to yeah yeah um so
you you set out a stance which i've not
i saw you do it first i'm not sure if
any other companies have done it but
publicly you were the first to say no
politics at work yeah
yeah i mean i think other companies are
doing variations of that um so it's not
entirely original but yeah i did put it
out in a way that was public and got a
lot of attention so
look i don't know i don't know what to
say about it i think
it's it started it starts from a very
good place which is people want to have
a safe space at work they want to have a
place where they can just be themselves
authentically like these all these
things actually start from a very good
place
what's unfortunate is that it can get to
a place where
the office is actually um
just very divided and people are upset
with each other all day instead of like
working towards the common mission that
we all kind of signed up for
um they're actually just upset with each
other and arguing over things which we
don't really have very much impact over
like bigger broader societal issues
outside of our mission
um this not just coinbase this is
happening broadly across a lot of
tech and all companies really it's not
just even a tech thing
it is it is more pronounced certain
places in the world it's not it's not a
broad thing geographically it's it's
very pronounced in some cities um
especially in the us but i guess
probably somewhat here as well
so
notice much
yeah i i i remember our ireland office
like there were some people who messaged
me during all that and they're like what
is you just said like we're gonna work
on work do work at work like what's
what's so controversial they didn't it
didn't make any sense um so it was it
was largely a thing that happened i
think in the bay area in the us and a
couple other cities like maybe brooklyn
portland places like that but
um look i i don't you know in some ways
i'd rather coinbase was like known for
our product innovation and stuff this is
a weird one because like we've actually
been pretty become kind of well known
for this stance and others have emulated
it but the thing that really made me
finally get the courage to do it because
i i i didn't really want to make a
public stance about this or whatever i
just want everybody to get back to work
but the reason i did it was that
i felt like i had been a bad leader
basically i had let this kind of
misunderstanding accumulate inside the
organization where people thought that
it was okay to like
come to work and just debate endlessly
these things or like at the q a that we
would host every week or two there would
be a lot of questions that were not
about our product or the regulators or
the the future it would be about like
these broader societal issues
and these kind of these brush fires kept
erupting in in slack channels and things
and so
oh and there and i think i reached a
place where i was like
i don't think i really want to be the
ceo of this company if like this is what
the ceo job entails is kind of like
getting put on the spot with like um
these crazy difficult societal questions
every week i kind of want to just build
cool stuff with technology and work on
our mission and so
i actually contemplated briefly i was
like am i the one who's like just not
sued for this job and maybe this is how
companies are run now and a bunch of i
talked to a bunch of friends of mine and
people and they were like
no like if if that's how you feel
there's probably a bunch of other people
the company who also feel that way
and like you started this company
you don't need to go they need to go and
so
it was if i realized i was like either
i'm gonna resign or they're gonna need
to resign and so at that point i was
like all right they need to resign so we
made we made an exit package available
like i clarified the stance of the
company five percent of the employees
opted into that package and left and
then after that it felt like the company
was much more aligned and we were all
able to
move towards the mission um so
it was cool to see some companies
emulate it afterwards and there's
probably a less dramatic way to do it
you know if you kind of said it that way
from the beginning but
um yeah that's where we are one of the
things that i really wanted to ask you
about because from reading your blog
post you have a very clear
strategy and perspective on this and i
also see this in hindsight as being the
single most important thing that i ever
had the responsibility of doing and
getting right which is hiring people
um i
i [ __ ] up for the first three years i
hired inexperienced people that were
cheap and that i felt i could manage
because i was 21 or 20. so i had a bunch
of you like you want a job you want a
job you want a job you can be director
director of this yeah my biggest mistake
i only learned when i hired someone good
and i saw the net impact they had and
the fact that good people then hired
good people
what advice would you give to people
that are hiring now and how important
do you consider hiring to be
super important i mean actually
in coinbase's values the number one
value is top talent in every seat
because
it really everything in the company
comes back to people like if you want to
have
a big impact you need to have
generate a bunch of revenue and profit
if you want good revenue property and
you make good products if you make good
products you have to have good people
build them so it's actually everything
comes back to people
um
so yeah i mean
it's interesting to hear that you
learned that lesson the hard way i've
hiring is super hard sometimes the only
way to learn a lesson is to actually go
make the mistake and and do it
but the mistake that a lot of startups
make i think is that they hire too fast
they treat the absence of any negatives
as a reason to hire whereas it should be
not just the absence of negatives but
hell yes meaning like
i learned something from this person
they they're way better than me at
something at least
you know i left the interview with more
energy than when i went in um
i
you know you can de-risk a lot of early
hiring also by just having people come
in and like try working together for a
week or two
interviews are actually really kind of a
low signal thing you have to get real
some people are great interviewers like
maybe five percent of people can really
assess someone in an interview most
people aren't that good at it naturally
and so you can basically use references
or
what we did in early days of coinbase we
actually just had people try working
with us for like a week or two a lot of
people can't do that because they have
an existing job but
some people can
and we you'll know you'll know within a
week or two like this person basically
delivered a bunch of stuff they got a
bunch of stuff done that was useful and
helped move the ball forward
or they didn't like it needed me it
needed me or someone else to come in and
edit their work or curate it and like
it's not to oversimplify it but
basically like
if the person can get a lot of stuff
done
that's advanced is the mission then you
want them on the team and if they can't
you shouldn't have them on the team and
that's basically what makes great
companies is like
you have a bunch of people aligned
toward a big impactful mission
who can actually get a lot of stuff done
every week
and um
you know you share some values in common
and then everything else
they can be quirky and weird and
different and like from every background
and walk of life and like everything
else can be
different but
if you have those pieces right they get
a lot of stuff done towards the mission
and they're aligned then you got a good
company you said about growing too fast
i i saw you post recently that you
you've grown the company too fast over
the last couple of years and that you
were having to cut back about 18 of the
workforce yeah
emotionally in those moments you know
the statements were you were very
transparent you were very honest you
didn't have to publish that to the
entire world but you did yeah
emotionally what are those moments like
does it get any easier for you to
to to cut back the workforce when you
you signaled in the memo that you take
responsibility for that as well like
you weren't skirting blame or anything
so
yeah so there's always something
challenging every year that like really
puts you out put you outside of your
comfort zone and that's part of what i
like about running a company is like
you're constantly learning so so this
year that was one of the things was like
we had never done a layoff before i had
never done one and um
yeah i did kind of suck to look back and
say um
ah i actually made them stick you know
we were everything everything crypto was
so up and up and up last year
that it it felt irresponsible not to
keep hiring more people because
we had like lines out our door you know
virtually of like customers trying to
sign up like institutional clients and
new products and competitors and all
these different markets and we were like
we're just being
reckless and irrational not to keep
building the company with all this
revenue we're generating and so but i
think we found the breaking point and
basically if you kind of more than
double a company in a year you're really
going to start to see a lot of stuff
break the culture erodes um decision
making is unclear communication channels
break down and so we we definitely like
exceeded that threshold last year in
2021 and earlier this year we were on a
pace to kind of keep going
too quickly
so
you know it really it really kind of is
a bad feeling to look at a problem and
say oop i made a mistake
but the only worst thing that is to like
bury your head in the sand and pretend
that you didn't make a mistake because
you don't want to admit it or whatever
and so um
facing reality
while it was deeply unpleasant and it
was really unpleasant for the people
that parted ways with the company
um
it was the right thing to do that now we
have the ability to kind of learn how to
operate really efficiently at this new
size 5000 people still a lot and get a
ton done with that
and we got the cost structure to a place
where we know that we can
not only um have enough cash but like
really thrive in this
in this recession we're all going
through at this point and whether that
lasts one year or three years or four
years whatever we're now we've set the
company up to ensure that it has a
better chance of accomplishing the
mission long term so
in a way although it was a super hard
decision and it was tough for a lot of
people involved it made me feel good
that we did the right thing
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
bluejeans yet but if you can't wait head
over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
this is an interesting question
that i just had when i was just just
thinking then yeah and because because
of this you know from my perspective i'd
call that stress sometimes stress is
great but there's a lot of volatility in
the markets and those tough decisions
if you view happiness as like a
concoction of as like a recipe and
there's lots of ingredients that go and
go into making us happy
um
what ingredients in your happiness
recipe
do you think you need more of
like today personally
um
oh wow
i mean
so i think it's getting very personal i
think you know people are get they're
basically happy
with
like health wealth relationships things
like that if you don't have your health
it's hard to really be happy you can't
really do anything
you don't need to be wealthy but you
need to have some level of security
where you're like i'm not worried about
like being hungry tomorrow or something
right
and then relationships account for a lot
of happiness i think
um
family like romantic leave personal
friendships
so um
i mean it's kind of it's i'm like almost
40 and i think
i'm thinking at some point i won't have
kids so that's probably like that's
probably an area but otherwise i think
yeah i feel quite happy about
relationships in my life
um personally professionally
romantically all that stuff so yeah i
didn't think you were gonna go there but
yeah yeah yeah there you go no i agree i
feel the same way i've had i've not had
enough balance in my life so my big next
chapter is um
allocating enough time to my girlfriend
and being i said it on stage today being
a dad and those things and prioritizing
that knowing the importance of it even
though i can't track it it's not revenue
so yeah we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest leaves
a question for the next guest they don't
know who they're writing it for okay um
their question was
what is the belief that you hold that
most people disagree with you on
hmm
give you some time well i mean one kind
of um contrarian view that i have that i
think most people would disagree with is
that
um
i think a lot of regulation is well
intentioned and it actually
causes more harm than good
um
you know
it's not really
probably a commonly held view in our
society because a lot of people haven't
tried to build something but if you've
just only been an employee to company or
you know consumed goods
um when something bad happens in society
people want to say what can we do to
make sure that never happens again and
so you create a rule
it's sort of human nature right um but
every rule has kind of these unintended
consequences down the road um
you know for instance uh
in the cryptocurrency industry right
like we're using kind of money
transmission laws that were originated
when there was like stage coaches moving
cash between states and so in the united
states we need to have 50 state licenses
plus multiple federal licenses and
that's just one small example you could
actually go down
many many many rules that are there in
society
they were created for a good reason at
the time but they they've now
accumulated so many of them
that it makes it harder to get um to get
innovation you know another good example
just randomly is like
in the us there's a the federal aviation
administration regulates like airplane
travel and things like that
they've been incredibly successful at
making airplane travel safe and so the
fatality rates in air traffic and
everything like that are airplane
flights are very low
but there's been an enormous cost to
society as well around the lack of
innovation so for instance
like the boeing jets that we fly today
they're very similar almost to the ones
that were in like the 1960s that jfk
flew on like
you can't go faster because it's they
they haven't allowed like people to
break the sound barrier over over land
um basically the things they're
innovating on are like fuel economy and
stuff like that and so
it it does stifle a lot of innovation
and so
people don't think about that cost
because they're more thinking about the
acute short-term problem
so i think it's a real risk that in
society basically enough rules
accumulate over time where it creates it
throws sand in the gears of progress and
um a lot of
new innovation is harmed by um by
regulation unfortunately even with good
intentions brian thank you thank you for
your time i realize you don't do things
like this very often so it feels like
even more of an honor for you to come
here today and coinbase as i said i'm a
customer of um it's it's always felt
like the most trusted the safest way to
involve myself in crypto and that's why
i've always stayed with with coinbase
and you as the ceo have a very
um innovative approach to building a
company in a new time in a new industry
which i've learned from as a business
owner myself so thank you for the
inspiration thank you for your blog post
as well i've sent many of them around to
my company i think i sent two to all of
my team today
around hiring and your 36 sort of
principles for retaining staff and
things like that so i implore people to
check out your blog post as well because
your blog as well because it's a source
of inspiration and knowledge and um
yeah thank you so much for being here it
truly truly is an honor and the
conversation has been inspiring to me so
thank you brian thank you i can see why
your podcast is so successful you're
really unique and amazing interviewers
so
um i really enjoyed the conversation
that was great thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like as
you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
sometimes a little bit aggressive with
my goals and determined and courageous
and brave the really wonderful thing
about crafty jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made
[Music]
[Music]
you